hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me just a heads up this video will have
spoilers for sixth and low's remembrance
of earth's past trilogy
the remembrance of earth's past trilogy
is one of the most existentially
terrifying book series i've ever read
the concepts explored in the books force
us to consider our place within the
cosmos
part of what drives the human spirit
forward is the belief that we can
continue to learn more about the
universe
the belief that we have boundless
potential
because from our perspective the
universe is mostly static
its movements are on a scale in which
humans can't truly comprehend
to us it feels stable and eternal
infinite and unchanging
of course we know that if we look
closely that none of this is true
the universe is a chaotic realm
constantly in motion
its secrets are endless
in the first book in the series the
three-body problem sixteen law
introduces the concept of
interdimensionality
it is greatly expanded upon in the third
book death sinned and fully extrapolated
upon in the spin-off novel redemption of
time by baesho
in death sin the crew of the ship blue
space discover that there are dead zones
in space
bubbles of space in which tricelerian
quantum entanglement could not penetrate
they come to understand the bubbles are
warp points
essentially entry points into the fourth
dimension
though the mysterious phenomenon was an
incredible discovery
there were also ominous undertones
why are there bubbles at all
why are there so many fourth dimensional
fragments in three-dimensional space
it's a great mystery
captain
i think it's likely a dark secret
from within the fourth dimension
three-dimensional space was laid out
clearly and in exquisite overwhelming
detail
in fact it was impossible for the human
brain to process the amount of
information they were being visually
exposed to from within the fourth
dimension
but members of blue space's crew
eventually learned to navigate the
fourth dimension
the brain that had been adapted from
birth to sense and feel
three-dimensional space could not handle
the infinite information generated by
countless details and initially
information overload threatened to shut
down processing but the brain soon grew
used to the four-dimensional environment
and without conscious thought it learned
to ignore most details leaving only the
frames around objects
the crew of blue space eventually used
their knowledge of the fourth dimension
and their access to warp points to
thwart a sophomore attack from the alien
beings known as the tricelerians
humanity had never been as far out into
space as the crew of blue space had
ventured during their more than 2000
year journey to the star system in
h558j2
eventually they realized the warp points
themselves are fragments of the fourth
dimension itself floating around in
three-dimensional space
though they still do not understand why
no other humans had ever studied this
phenomenon
though it was possible that humans could
have encountered fourth-dimensional
space but not realized
do you think we'll encounter more in the
future
i think there's an even more interesting
question
have we encountered them before
think about the earth it's been
careening through space for several
billion years
is it not possible that it had entered a
fourth dimensional fragment in the past
the crew of blue space eventually do
journey deep into the fourth dimension
approaching a giant ring
a remnant of some ancient long gone
civilization
after deciphering the language of the
crew
it is able to communicate with them
ominously it calls itself a tomb
whose tomb is this
the tomb of those who created it
is it a spaceship
it used to be a spaceship but now it's
dead and so it's a tune
who are you
who is conversing with us
i am the tomb it is the tomb speaking to
you
i'm dead
you mean you're a ship whose crew died
in other words you're the control system
for the ship
there is no reply to this
we can see many other objects in this
region of space are they also tombs
most of them are tombs
the others will be tombs soon
i don't know them all
are you from far away or have you always
been here
i am from far away
they are also from far away from
different places far away
where
there was no answer
from their conversation with the thing
referring to itself as a tomb they are
given information about the twisted
nature of the universe but they don't
initially process what they are told
the fourth dimension in which it resided
had once been a sea
but now it was a puddle
the sea had dried up
the tomb was there among so many other
tombs and soon to be tombs because just
as fish must gather into puddles to
survive in a drying sea
so must they
but it was the next part of the
communication that was the most
important more important than anything
else
some had begun to hope that the
so-called dark force state of the
universe was not persistent throughout
the entirety of the cosmos
what the tomb said next would shatter
those hopes
the puddle is also drying
all the fish are going to disappear
are all the fish here
the fish responsible for drying the sea
are not here
we're sorry what you said is really hard
to understand
the fish who dried the sea went on to
land before they did this
they moved from one dark forest to
another dark forest the fragments of the
fourth dimension existed throughout
three-dimensional space for one simple
reason
all of space had once been fourth
dimensional
but it too had been a dark forest
any intelligent life that made itself
known was wiped out
but according to the tomb those who had
destroyed the fourth dimension
would not meet the same fate as the
tombs for they had moved from the fourth
dimension into the third
the fish that had dried the sea had
crawled out onto land before doing so
we later discovered that the universe at
its birth had in fact been 10
dimensional
the speed of light then had been close
to infinity
light back then was capable of action at
a distance and could go from one end of
the cosmos to the other within plank
time
if you had ever been to fourth
dimensional space you would have some
vague hint of how beautiful that
10-dimensional garden must have been
the endless wars in the dark forest had
caused one dimension after the other to
be imprisoned from the macroscopic into
the microscopic each time reducing the
speed of light
within the dark forest one of the ways
for advanced civilizations to eliminate
an enemy is through a dimension strike
which causes the space around it to
collapse into lower dimensions
the problem is
dimensional collapse never ends it
continues to expand until everything
collapses
there is no way to stop a dimension
strike once activated
so like the dimensions before it the
third dimension was also collapsing and
could not be stopped
so eventually the entire universe would
collapse into a single dimension and all
life would cease to be
humanity never got the opportunity to
see the actual universe in its original
state
and never would
and in the end nothing would be
preserved
this idea seems sad and it is
and yet
everything dies
everything is forgotten
why should the universe be any different
there is a kind of grand sense of final
equality that this idea invokes
all of us
every soul who ever lived throughout the
cosmos
all meet at the end
in darkness
thanks for watching guys make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas
you